dans la province de salta dans le
nord-ouest de l'argentine
ces indigènes wish i sont touchés de
plein fouet par la pauvreté et
l'insalubrité une situation dramatique
qui a mené à la mort de huit enfants de
la communauté durant le seul mois de
janvier dernier
[Musique]
première cause de cette crise sanitaire
l'eau consommée par les indigènes qui
provoque diarrhée et déshydratation la
communauté wish i est désormais la plus
touchée par la mortalité infantile dans
toute l'argentine
le gouverneur de la province a décrété
la question urgence de santé publique
dans un pays où le taux de pauvreté
dépasse désormais 35% les populations
indigènes
restent les plus vulnérables